i was probably at the age of three when
i first started making things and
mimicking them off of movies
i wasn't so interested in characters it
was more of the objects they use
it was something that oh my gosh i want
to do what that character is doing with
that problem i would want something that
was exactly like i saw on the big screen
so that's why i resorted to making my
own
[Music]
my name is kennen spivey i'm an artist
and prop maker
[Music]
at first it was cardboard duct tape i
was making costumes prop swords vehicles
starships really hit me when i was in
high school where i actually got
introduced to metal work it was about
that time that i decided hey i'm going
to make a sword the first attempt was
horrible it kind of dawned on me that
there's a lot more that goes into this
than just the blacksmith's job so the
most logical thing that i could think of
doing was to master all of these crafts
i had to learn blacksmithing for the
blade leather work for the sheath and
the handle
engraving
lavatory for cutting the stone setting
skills
i traveled all across the u.s i was
trying to learn as much as i could
i decided i was going to open up my own
business and to get really proficient
really fast i started making knives
200 later i started having people
call and ask me how i did things
like i said i made this look easy
i started teaching classes
the goal of becoming a prop maker never
went away but i really felt that this is
a long shot it's akin to you know a
little kid wanting to become an
astronaut or something
[Music]
the stars aligned rather suddenly
the movie industry had moved over to the
atlanta region and that led to my first
real gig yep the rest is history
my focus is on swords knives daggers
i've worked on many movies many shows
even stage productions
it's
nerve-racking at times to drive up to a
movie set and have a proper hand but
it's also very exciting
i know now that there might be some kid
out there who's watching these films
seeing these pieces and just like me
saying
how can i make that it's pretty cool